tell us a bit about today's game tell us
a bit about your estim estimation about
your performance at this
Championship well thank you guys it's
nice to be back but first I'd like to
say a big congratulation to Fabian
Karana for winning his third us Chess
Championship it was a very well-deserved
Victory I he could have won an extra
more game actually but uh yeah he's he's
been playing really really well recently
he also almost won nor he won
Romania um and he's also playing very
well on speed on faster time controls
which I'm not sure how you do that you
do you play well but uh yeah uh well the
third Victory I and uh I hope he I hope
he keeps it up uh especially for next
year's Olympiad maybe we can finally win
another gold medal absolutely yeah big
Olympiad is coming up